as we slowly return to normal many of  you may still be cautious about taking  off your mask  or being around people who already have  psychology  psychologists say it's normal to feel  anxious about going back  out in public after this pandemic and  those anxieties  stem from a fear of standing out so they  say just take things to your own pace  different people move at different paces  anxieties  around you know what it feels like to  maybe look  different or to be making different  choices when out in public  and what that may result in in terms of  what people are thinking i think  is a normal emotional response i think  that  you know humans want to feel like they  fit in  doctors say it's going to take time to  feel normal again so  don't feel rushed to take off the mask  if you're not ready even with the  restrictions being lifted